hey there Boyle how was your weekend
well actually I got a little sick oh
really sorry to hear that man yeah
Bullets Over Broadway was on TV I came
down with a big old Diane Wiest
infection
like yeast
Amy when did you get here you've come
for my conjugal capabilities
you're looking not real good girl
pasta booby no matter
I'll just build another one
wait for it wait for it 901 Amy Santiago
is officially late for the first time
ever all right let's do this who's got
theories uh uh alarm didn't go up all
three alarms all with battery backup
come on who wants to take this seriously
oh she was taken in her sleep that's
what I'm talking about super dark foil
but way more plausible than the Sarge's
idiotic alarm clock Theory I bet she
tucked herself into bed too tight and
got stuck maybe she fell into another
dimension where she's interesting it's 9
A.M
why is no one working Amy Santiago is a
few minutes late and we're all trying to
guess why I like to play
I'd say she's in line at the bank
this is fun it is fun but you're all
wrong she clearly slipped through a
Subway grade and is having terrible sex
with a mole man
there she is Amy where have you been
we've been worried sick do you care to
explain yourself I'm just 70 seconds
late it's not a big deal don't worry
about it Santiago you will tell us and
you will tell us now
there's a problem at the bank God damn
sure you took that Chardonnay to the
house how you feeling let me take stock
my equilibrium is Askew my vision is
partially impaired and I'm clearly
slurring my words to put a fine point on
it your boy's turn I have something I
need to talk to you about
you about I might get a promotion to
Major Crimes they asked me to come in
and interview for a job what you're
gonna go work for the vulture have you
forgotten how awful he is
the Vladimir Putin collection yeah 70
bucks a pair and the only increase in
value
I guess that's your new best friend now
Santiago emphasis on Iago backstabber
I'm surprised you read a fellow what the
hell's a fellow I'm calling you the
parrot from Aladdin I mean I can teach
you guys how to fake take real drugs
like a pro I used to do it all the time
when I was undercover all you got to do
is close your nostril when you go down
watch this
nope I didn't do it that time I got a
full snout folk okay no let me just try
it again I'm a little rusty all you got
to do just close the old Master Roni and
then oh boy I got more that time
where did you get this Adrian that's
enough oh we can make fake cocaine for
ourselves out of vitamin B powder ooh
vitamin B the second best vitamin guys
I'm telling you the fake starting can
work what oh
[Music]
oh I got so much that time oh anybody
want to listen to Jamiroquai right now
okay I'm just gonna move this away from
your nose hole well you two should get
going if Hawkins tells you anything text
me right away I'll stay here and watch
Adrian who's Adrian yeah all right hey
yeah you guys playing instrument you
know I play a little bit of Bouzouki
anybody else play an ancient string at
instrument no you guys want to go to the
beach beautiful day just maybe like get
out there throw the disc around right
hey have you ever been to the Statue of
Liberty Captain have you have you been
inside like under the skirt like what's
up there did they build a you know what
I'm saying guys watch this I'm gonna
juggle no no no no no no no no no I
gotta find Ocampo before Rosa does so
wound up I can't focus oh are you
flipping out about Tiandra getting
kicked off So You Think You Can Dance
definitely not well you should be her
Nae Nae was non-paray
I know what's happening
I'm finally hydrated and it's unlocking
my brain's full potential it's too much
for me I'm Limitless thing I don't think
water makes you jittery it does if it's
laced with caffeine
you dosed my water you destroyed 960
cups of coffee oh that expressway I know
talk butter are you having sterk good
luck solving that case why would you
drink more my brain wants its fast juice
the worst part is Olson got away that's
the worst part you could have died man I
wasn't hurt that badly the doctor said
all my bleeding was internal that's
where the blood's supposed to be
here
I gave Captain hold his gift oh did he
lift his no gift policy no he didn't but
I figured out a way to buy him something
and trick him into accepting it you are
bad
oh wait you're making fun of me well I
don't care he would never open a gift
right but what if his gift didn't look
like a gift he would open it exactly I
left it in a cardboard box on his desk
there's no card just the words open now
which I wrote with my wrong hand so he
wouldn't recognize my handwriting
so just to recap you left an unmarked
package on a police Captain's desk on a
random Monday with a suspicious message
written on it looked like it was
scrawled by a crazy person mom there's a
bomb everyone else
let's go
great gift babe guys guys
Scully has a mason jar full of lemonade
you called us in here to tell us that no
I called you in here to change your
lives for you see a mere five minutes
ago Hitchcock introduced me to his new
goldfish who lives in an identical mason
jar oh this isn't gonna end well there
are two possible outcomes and we're
gonna bet on which one happens first so
will Hitchcock put fish food and
scully's lemonade or will Scully drink
Hitchcock's goldfish now you would think
that putting fish food into lemonade
Hitchcock just drank his own fish what
no
oh
I read an article in the medical journal
that said one destabilizing aspect of
the incarceration is the constant
dehumanization Rosa you need to be
reminded that you're more than just a
number Rosa you are Rosa
Rosa yep that fixes prison is there
anything we can do to help you anything
you need done on the outside no I'm good
it's not a problem Rosa we're here for
you Rosa whatever you need Rosa
she's worried about her motorcycle
sitting idle so she wants us to take it
out once a day here
I think you should do this you're more
the biker type I've seen you use a
toothpick in public motorcycles are
death machines I have three kids I'm not
risking it are you saying my life
matters less because I don't conform to
society's heteronormative child-centric
ideals are you really playing the gay
card right now yes Queen
is everything okay Santiago no
see where it went actually actually
it's behind one of these three doors why
don't you pick one are you trying to
Monty hole me it's unbelievable I don't
need Monty Hall ruining my place of work
but Monty Hall has already ruined my
home life come on Sir the math thing
isn't the problem night shift's keeping
you and Kevin apart you two just need a
bone
what did you say don't say it again I
said you two need a bone
oh
Dare You detective Diaz I am your
Superior officer phone what happens in
my bedroom detective is none of your
business
don't ever speak to me like that again
why did you choose that dude to spin up
now he knows problem solved